This type of diagram--called a slope field--helps to understand why everything is determined
once we fix a certain initial amount of fish in this case.
The general term would be initial value.
These arrows point in the direction in which our solution curve has to run at every point in time
and every amount fish we could draw such an arrow.
This arrow specifies the rate of change.
Here the rate of change is slightly positive. Here it's approximately zero.
Here it's slightly negative and here it is really hugely negative.
To see what this system is doing, we simply follow these arrows or take this one here as an initial value.
We first have to go down and then move from between here.
Once you have specified the initial condition to initial value in this case the initial amount of fish,
you can trace out such a solution curve that describes the dependency of the amount of fish
on time or whatever your differential equation is about.
There is such a solution curve and there is no second solution curve. This would not work.
This is what mathematicians mean when they speak of existence and uniqueness of the solution.
Once you specified the initial condition, there is a solution curve and there is only one solution curve.
Well, unless I have to say first thing that may happen is that the solution escapes infinity
in finite time then we don't know how to continue afterward or the solution may fall into a hole
of the definition set of our equations.
For instance imagine that we are simulating a machine and we do not have any idea about
what's happening to the machine in this region then we can't continue either.
The following quiz shows that this escape to infinity in finite time can happen easily.